all right you know it wasn't that long
ago where there were some people in the
world that you know thought giannis was
done you know wasn't going to win the
finals and you know the suns were going
to take it and then giannis would just
drift away
no one else uh thought that like i said
there were some brilliant people just
about a month and a half ago that
thought if giannis keeps shooting free
throws like he has been oh i don't know
his entire life they probably won't win
the finals but then
you know god touched him and he went 17
for 18 in game six of the nba finals
and wow has his life changed since then
so since then giannis
giannis
greek freak yeah the greek freak so
since then
wow it's been a whirlwind so after the
parade in milwaukee he ends up buying an
ownership stake in the milwaukee brewers
which is very exciting and very cool and
something that he seemed he was really
really excited about
he has a sports drink that he's a
co-owner in right and and now gonzaga
the basketball team and the entire
athletic department has made it their
official sports drink i mean
is that gonna be hard for mark few to
recruit athletes to gonzaga now oh by
the way giannis is the owner of our
sports drink come meet giannis right not
they need they need any recruiting
advantages but they have even more
giannis is going to be their biggest fan
because he's going to want that to sell
and do very very well so because of the
nba championship giannis is now
maybe 1a the biggest star in the nba
maybe number one i mean he's the king
right now and it's just unbelievable how
your fortunes as an athlete can change
when you win a championship we wouldn't
be talking about him if he hasn't and
and he's he's following an interesting
path right now because he's signed long
term you know eight or ten years with
milwaukee he's going to be a mainstay
there he got the max and it kind of
reminds you a little bit about what what
patrick mahomes is doing with the kansas
city chiefs you have another guy in a
small market who took over that city by
storm who everybody has embraced who he
has actually welcomed the community and
really want to contribute and be part of
it and been that familiar face him and
his wife i mean everybody loves patrick
obviously around the whole country but
in kansas city it's something special
and something different you know i think
you could put larry fitzgerald in that
category as well and you know he did the
same thing he bought a little piece of
the phoenix sun so you have these elite
athletes that own a city right for their
accomplishments and winning a
championship but it looks like they
really want to put some long-term roots
in there and phil back you know even
like a few years ago
athletes wanted to get to new york or
l.a because that's where they thought
the money was but that's right there's
almost seems to be a blueprint right
here now it helps if you win a
championship even though larry
fitzgerald never did russell wilson he's
almost on that same level in seattle
your hometown but do you think this is
something that other athletes notice and
think man you know what it might not be
so bad being in cincinnati or tampa or
denver or something like that i think
it's great because they're showing their
entrepreneur's spirit right and they're
making good use out of those max deals
that's what i'm most impressive with is
that
we always hear about the the horror
stories and i'm sure you've seen a ton
being around the nba and stuff like that
how often athletes just burn through
cash well if you're going to invest in
anything you can invest in another team
just like an owner would like the owner
of your team has it probably has a
soccer club over in europe maybe runs a
race car company or whatever these are
great because this
to me
shows a
longevity within the community he's the
basketball player but he's also doing
stuff like you said with gonzaga
he's doing stuff with the milwaukee
brewers i love to know that like
champions are trying to stay put yeah
and with patrick mahomes i mean that
contract was a beast yeah that was a
beast and to know that like again like
he is investing in his community he's
going to be there and as a fan if you're
living there you're thinking
i'm going to root for him
always because he's going to be he's
going to have a monument here yeah it
gives you more civic pride when you know
that a famous athlete who just brought
you a championship cares as much about
your hometown as you do that really
resonates with a lot of people
especially sports fans you know kd is
another guy who man he's almost known as
much for his investments right now yeah
i mean the people that he hooked up with
when he played with the warriors i mean
he got involved in the tech industry in
a big way same thing now in brooklyn but
man you're really seeing these guys it's
almost impossible to go broke if you're
an nba star like back in the day you
hear the horror stories that they're
spending all the money but now there's
just too much i mean that's not even
counting their 200 million shoe deal
right yeah 100 yeah and
the world itself again is evolving uh i
mean we were talking earlier just even
about media and how media is changing
right and you know there's other places
you can go you can go to warner brothers
and go to these studios these older
entities that would be equivalent to
like la or new york but
because social media and streaming and
just the way the world is evolving uh it
it it really evens the playing field for
every uh other sports as well um but
each city now has almost an equal
opportunity because you can go global
because of technology you can go all
over the place yeah it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter the size of the city and
if you're relevant and you're a star you
know the only guy that is kind of doing
the opposite of that is aaron rodgers if
you think about it even though he has
invested in the milwaukee bucks he's a
part owner of the nba team
he's always got one foot out the door
kind of and i think this is actually it
for him he's he's but green bay is
different i don't know if you guys have
ever been there and it's it's charming
and it certainly has its appeal but it
is a small town yeah i mean it's smaller
than a college town and for a guy like
aaron at some point you just maybe need
a little bit more stimulation right
there's no way to leave that dates the
hollywood actresses
yeah and he's a california guy so i mean
it's the perfect place to be in the in
the summer and fall right winners are a
little tough but man going to soldier
field or going to um lambeau field is is
for a california guy man and you got to
do that for 15 years like he's had to
it's a lot of cold afternoons
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]